[Aplausos]
lo bueno que pasen estas cosas es que ya
no puedo estar más nerviosos ella esté
al tope
les contaba que yo me interesé por el
tema de la libertad religiosa cuando
estaba empezando el doctorado aunque ya
tenía decidido que iba a ser mi tesis en
algo relacionado a la libertad religiosa
y si se me vino a la mente que lo había
elegido como cuando uno elige un
aromatizador
mira la etiqueta y dice
encanto del bosque andino
suave toques del sol del mediterráneo
libertad de conciencia y religión
a veces la etiqueta nos puede sonar bien
pero la verdad es que no sabemos del
todo qué aroma va a tener cuando
lleguemos a casa y abramos el envoltorio
así que me consigue una pila de libros y
me puse a investigar a tratar de
averiguarlo al arriendo chiquitito que
era una historia universal de las
relaciones entre el estado y la religión
y me llama la atención de un par de
cosas lo primero es que el autor no
hablaba acerca de la religión sino
únicamente acerca de su religión y más
concretamente de su propia iglesia
pero lo que me dejó totalmente
desconcertado fue que al hablar de los
eventos de la historia celebraba como
grandes victorias de la libertad
religiosa los momentos en los cuales su
propia iglesia lograba imponer su dogma
sobre el gobierno y sobre la población y
al contrario como derrotas de la
libertad religiosa los momentos en los
cuales esa influencia se veía disminuida
yo estaba comenzando mi carrera
académica pero me acuerdo que en ese
momento tuve un pensamiento que no fue
del todo académico me acuerdo estar
sentado ahí y pensar
esto es la libertad religiosa pero qué
porquería
yo quiero saber nada con esto me huele
muy mal
desde ese momento de ese choque inicial
tuve oportunidad durante muchos años de
dedicar una enorme cantidad de horas a
leer
a conversar a pensar acerca de la
libertad de conciencia y religión y
aprendí una cosa que quiero compartir
con este eso
cuando leemos la etiqueta en libertad
religiosa no todos estamos hablando de
lo mismo
vieron cuando uno busca en el gps por un
lugar y aparece en la lista de
resultados otro lugar que tiene el mismo
nombre pero que queda a tres mil
kilómetros de distancia y uno piensa
siguiendo esta indicación podría haber
llegado muy lejos de donde realmente
quería ir y un poco así pasa con la
libertad religiosa y de conciencia
evidentemente hay un núcleo común de
ideas que todos los que usan esa
etiqueta tienen por ejemplo decimos que
la libertad religiosa es un derecho
fundamental decimos que es el derecho
que tengo de elegir mis propias
creencias de cambiarla si quiero de
manifestarlas pero a partir de ese
momento el camino comienza a bifurcarse
muy pronto
pensemos en preguntas como esta la
libertad religiosa pertenece a todos por
igual yo puedo hacer diferencias entre
las personas de acuerdo a sus creencias
oa sus creencias
quién puede definir qué es una creencia
religiosa y que no lo es
qué papel en que jugar el estado en esto
tiene que limitarse a no perseguir a las
personas por su religión tiene que
apoyar a las religiones
tiene que crear un espacio de libertad
las respuestas para estas preguntas y
para muchas otras difieren hay distintas
respuestas pero lo que nos deja
perplejos es que todas esas respuestas
utilizan el mismo rótulo libertad
religiosa
así que hace a riesgo de simplificar yo
voy a proponer que las diferencias entre
estas visiones entre estas distintas
respuestas están basadas en dos
actitudes bien opuestas
la primera es pensar que la libertad
religiosa es un derecho para mí
si yo tengo derecho de elegir mi
religión y vivir conforme con ella los
demás pasando a un segundo plano puede
ser que también reclamé este derecho
para otros que creen como yo por ejemplo
personas que comparten mi religión o que
sin compartir mi religión coinciden
conmigo en determinados temas concretos
fundamentales
ahora uno se pregunta qué pasa con el
resto con los que crean diferente o
piensan diferente
en el mejor de los casos se les ofrece
tolerancia esta mezcla de indiferencia
con concesión generosa pero claro la
tolerancia funciona únicamente mientras
esos otros pasen desapercibidos no
molesten no comienzan a reclamar sus
derechos cuando quieren ser iguales
entonces surgen las tensiones y la
tolerancia desaparece muy pronto
cuando pienso que la libertad religiosa
es un derecho para mí para mi grupo y no
tengo problemas de que ese derecho se le
niegue a los demás
entonces la consecuencia lógica es que
en muy poco tiempo no voy a tener
problema tampoco de pensar que mi
creencia se puede imponer sobre la de
los otros y lo peor de todo es que voy a
seguir llamando a eso con la etiqueta
libertad religiosa y esta es una de las
paradojas de la libertad
tradicionalmente han sido los disidentes
los grupos minoritarios los
desaventajados los que han defendido más
vigorosamente la idea de libertad
religiosa lo cual es completamente
lógico por son los que no pueden
imponerse a los demás los que no pueden
ganar elecciones lo que no pueden tomar
el poder y sin embargo vez tras vez
aquel que ha sufrido la imposición de
los demás cuando tiene la posibilidad
busca imponer su propio sistema de
creencias o de increencias
el oprimido cuando tiene oportunidad se
convierte en opresor
este es un patrón que se repite a lo
largo de la historia que incluso podemos
ver en nuestros propios días vemos
grupos colectivos comunidades que han
sufrido persecución desprecio
discriminación durante muchísimo tiempo
pero que cuando tienen la oportunidad
buscan imponer su sistema de creencias a
los demás
y hay otro patrón que se repite también
a lo largo de la historia y es la idea
de alcanzar la unidad por medio de la
uniformidad
como si el argumento fuera
sólo podremos estar verdaderamente
unidos cuando todos crean y piensen lo
mismo que yo que soy que tengo la verdad
por supuesto que no está mal creer que
uno tiene la verdad tener la convicción
de la certeza de las propias creencias
el tema es que hago yo con esa
convicción si voy más allá de defender
mi propio mi propia libertad para
intentar imponer mis creencias a los
demás entonces ya no puedo estar
hablando de libertad y de hecho no
importa la etiqueta que utilice eso
siempre va a ser lo contrario a la
libertad
afortunadamente hay otra forma de ver
todo este asunto
desde este otro punto de vista
la libertad religiosa solo puede existir
si es para todos
es decir si yo respeto el derecho de
todos y cada uno de elegir libremente
sus convicciones sin importar lo que le
diga al estado o lo que decía la mayoría
en su esencia más íntima la libertad
religiosa es la libertad de disentir de
no estar de acuerdo
si lo pensamos por un segundo esto es
una idea muy radical y que tiene unas
implicancias totalmente distintas a las
que vimos recién
si uno cree que la libertad religiosa es
para todos
nunca la puede ver como un garrote para
agredir a los demás sino siempre como un
escudo para defender su propio derecho
libertad de creer nunca puede significar
libertad de imponer las creencias
si uno cree que la libertad religiosa es
para todos
tendrá que aceptar
que el derecho a libertad religiosa
incluye la posibilidad de estar
equivocado no puede ser como alguno cree
que sólo hay que perteneció cree
pertenecer a la iglesia verdadera tiene
derecho de libertad religiosa la
libertad de elegir por su propia esencia
significa si implica siempre la libertad
elegir mal
si uno cree que la libertad religiosa
verdaderamente es para todos tiene que
estar de acuerdo en que no puede haber
auténtica libertad a menos que haya
igualdad
la desigualdad del privilegio socava la
libertad por eso no basta con que todos
tengamos derecho de libertad religiosa
sino que todos tenemos que estar en
igualdad de condiciones para disfrutar
de ese hecho
si uno cree que la libertad religiosa es
para todos entenderá que aunque a
primera vista pueda parecer algo
distinto un estado religioso es tan
nocivo como un estado anti religioso y
viceversa
la neutralidad del estado en materia de
religión es decir que el estado no
perjudique ni apoye a ninguna religión
no es una amenaza en contra de la
libertad religiosa sino es la mejor
garantía de su protección
por supuesto todo esto es mucho más
fácil de decir que de hacer no hay una
vieja frase que habrán escuchado de
voltaire que en realidad voltaire nunca
le dijo que dice no estoy de acuerdo con
lo que crees pero daría con lo que dices
pero daría mi vida para que puedas
decirlo y es una frase muy bonita pero
la verdad es muy difícil de llevar a la
práctica
así que en definitiva creo que la
pregunta que tenemos que hacernos es por
qué defender no solamente en mi libertad
sino la de todos y yo tengo dos razones
para ofrecerles
la primera porque es lo correcto para
hacer porque es una cuestión de
principios
todas o casi todas las grandes
religiones por ejemplo tienen alguna
especie de regla de oro alguna norma
moral que nos manda a tratar a los demás
no como quisiéramos
no como nos tratan sino como quisiéramos
que nos traten
si seguimos esta regla la lógica indica
que si queremos disfrutar de nuestra
libertad tenemos que respetar la
libertad de los demás pero incluso fuera
de las creencias religiosas la idea de
libertad para todos se puede extraer del
concepto general de dignidad humana
universal yo tengo el deber de respetar
a los demás cuando elige sus
convicciones cuando eligen su camino
vital aunque no coincida con el mío
simplemente porque son seres humanos
igual que yo y tienen derecho a recibir
ese respeto
a veces puede pasar que las crisis el
miedo no se empujen a dejar un poco de
lado estos principios oa pensar que un
fin noble justifica la utilización de
cualquier medio
y ahí es donde entran a jugar los
principios porque los principios son esa
brújula moral que nos orienta para
mantener el rumbo en todas las
condiciones cuando son adversas o cuando
son favorables
sin principios nuestra toma de
decisiones queda relegada únicamente a
la oportunidad que tengamos si esto
moralmente es muy peligroso
pero incluso para quienes comparten
estos principios hay otra razón no son
más prácticas
por la cual defender la libertad de
todos y es simplemente esta porque
funciona
y acá se da otra paradoja de la libertad
mi libertad religiosa que consiste
básicamente en el derecho que tengo de
adherirme a las creencias que yo pienso
que son correctas y que son verdaderas
sólo funciona si al mismo tiempo
garantizó ese derecho para los demás que
tienen otras creencias que por
definición para mí son menos verdaderas
por no decir totalmente falsas
podemos pensar
en la libertad como si fuera un alfajor
cualquier chico sin haber sido nunca
filosofía del derecho sabe cómo se
divide de la manera más justa un alfajor
entre dos personas uno corta
el otro elige primero
el que corta sabe que si se pasa un
milímetro de la mitad indefectiblemente
el otro va a elegir la mitad más grande
y le va a dejar a él la más pequeña
así de justos deberíamos ser cuando se
trata de establecer reglas de juego
acerca de las libertades
puede ser que en algún momento estamos
en una posición de poder y nos vemos
tentados a cortar una mitad más grande
para quedarnos con esa pero el poder es
circunstancial las mayorías cambian y
capaz que mañana nos encontramos
recibiendo la porción pequeña que
nosotros mismos generamos ayer
esto me hace pensar en la historia de
martín demoler demoler era un pastor
luterano meliana alemán ya la década del
30 que le apoyó la llegada de un nuevo
gobierno que aunque amenazaba con
recortar ciertas libertades para algunos
grupos prometía imponer en la sociedad
una agenda moral mucho más acorde a las
creencias del propio ni molar
el líder de este gobierno ustedes las
imagina se llamaba adolf hitler ni
envolver se dio cuenta pronto de su
error se opuso al régimen nazi y fue
enviado a un campo de concentración y
estando en su celda su compañero un
judío le pregunta cómo pudiste apoyar a
hitler demolerlo respondió me sentí tan
amenazado por la hostilidad que
mostraban los ateos y los comunistas en
contra de la religión que eso me empujó
a poner mis esperanzas en hitler fue un
error terrible me arrepiento y lo estoy
pasando yo y muchos como yo
cuando terminó la guerra demoler sus
sermones frecuentemente repetía unas
palabras que terminaron convirtiéndose
en una especie de poemas muy conocidos
cuando vinieron a buscar a los
comunistas a los ateos a los judíos yo
no protesté porque yo no era ninguna de
esas cosas cuando vinieron a buscarme a
mí ya no quedaba nadie para que proteste
no importa lo seguro que estemos de
nuestras convicciones no importa los
nobles que sean nuestros valores nunca
deberíamos permitir que eso sea una
excusa para recortar las libertades de
otros ni para apoyar aquel que lo hace
ahora
alguno puede pensar bueno todas estas
son cuestiones muy abstractas muy
filosóficas no tiene ninguna importancia
para nuestra vida cotidiana si piensan
así los invito simplemente a que lean
las noticias oa que miren a su alrededor
lo que está pasando estamos viviendo en
momentos muy delicados de la historia en
un caldo del cultivo no tan lejano aquel
que dio lugar al nazismo y otros
horrores
vivimos inmersos en una constante
polarización todo es nosotros contra
ellos todo es religiosos con drug
gnósticos musulmanes contra cristianos
religiosos conservadores contra
religiosos liberales
todo es considerar al otro al diferente
como si fuera un enemigo y en ese
contexto las creencias o las injerencias
se pueden convertir en la excusa para
agredir o para segregar al otro
la idea de libertad para todos ayuda a
diluir esa polarización ya romper el
círculo vicioso de oprimido opresor
la idea de libertad para todos es clave
para construir unidad en la diversidad
porque estamos verdaderamente unidos no
cuando todos creemos y pensamos
exactamente lo mismo sino cuando somos
capaces de convivir con nuestras
diferencias y cuando podemos
enriquecernos todos a partir de ellas
la libertad religiosa no puede ser una
etiqueta que se ponga sobre cualquier
producto porque la libertad religiosa
cuando es auténtica tiene el aroma
refrescante de la libertad para todos
[Aplausos]